hey everybody i'm off the grid for
august but my team wanted to highlight
this clip from black lesbian press
secretary karine jean-pierre
so two questions sure uh only
semi-fascism come in yeah is this
something we're gonna hear more of that
phrase is it something the president's
going to kind of embrace or is there any
sense that it was uh
you know a little impromptu and it's
going to turn into a kind of basket of
deplorables thing that he regrets and
tries to be quiet about
look i was very clear when uh when
laying out uh and defining uh what uh
you know mega republicans have done and
you look at the definition of fascism
and you think about uh what they're
doing in attacking our democracy what
they're doing and taking away uh our
freedoms uh taking away wanting to take
away our rights our voting rights i mean
that is what that is it is very clear
and that's why he made that um that
that powerful speech that you heard uh
from him last night and he has not shied
away from saying that you have heard him
uh maybe not use that specific word but
you have heard him certainly use that
definition
and look
what we again what we are putting before
the american people is is a choice right
and it is clear there is a clear
contrast of what is happening on that
side of the aisle and what's happening
on our side with congressional democrats
and what we have been delivering for the
american people and we're going to
continue to fight for uh freedom we're
going to continue to fight for people's
rights uh and that is not uh
that is something that he takes very
seriously and that's what you heard from
him last night